العاصمه الروسيه مجددا في المرمى
الاوكراني هذه المره على نحو اوسع واشد
فمسيره
قلب موسكو فجرا اوقعتا اضرار في المباني
والشوارع المجاوره فضلا عن حاله الهلع
وفقدان الطمانينه في اوساط السكان جاء
الهجوم الجديد محملا ايضا بدلالات رمزيه
مهمه فاحدى المسييرتين تحطمت قرب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بينما اصابه الاخرى مركزا
للاعمال في احد شوارع موسكو الرئيسيه ثم
ان اوكرانيا تبنت الهجوم وهو امر نادر
الحدوث خلال هجمات سابقه استهدفت العمق
الروسي وموسكو تحديدا الجيش الروسي اعلن
اسقاط المسيارتين ووزاره الخارجيه اعتبرت
في بيان العمليه ارهابا واكدت احتفاظ
روسيا بحق اتخاذ اجراءات رد قاسيه واشار
البيان الى ان الدول الغربيه تق ف خلف
افعال كيف وقد صرح نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي ديمتري ان على روسيا انتقاء
اهداف نوعيه وغير متوقعه في اوكرانيا
لضرباتها الانتقاميه
لا يعرف ما اذا كان استهداف موسكو جزءا من
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لكن من المعلوم
تماما انا الرئيس فولودو مرزلينسكي تعهد
برد على الضربات الروسيه على الاسبوع
الماضي وقد اعلنت قياده العمليات
الاوكرانيه في جنوب البلاد ان هجوما روسيا
جديدا بالمسيرات استهدف منشات في مرافق
منطقه اوديسا ودمر صومعه حبوب تطورات
عسكريه لكنها قد لا تنفصل عن قرار موسكو
بالانسحاب من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود وفي شبه
جزيره القرم قصفت مسيرات اوكرانيه مستودع
ذخيره للجيش الروسي الذي اعلن ان قواته
اسقطت عده مسيرات اوكرانيه عبر انظمه
التشويش وبمضادات الطائرات
وعلى صعيد الحرب البريه قالت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان قوات بلادها استعادت
نحو 230 كيلومترا مربعا من الجيش الروسي
ضمن هجومها المضاد الذي بداته منذ بضعه
اسابيع ومن تلك الاراضي المستعاده مساحات
حول مدينه باخموت واخرى شرق منطقه دونيس